the murder of two u.n workers in
democratic republic of congo in 2017
made international headlines
they were killed in a country that
remains one of the most underreported in
the world
zeida catalan was swedish michael sharp
american the two were investigating mass
graves in the kasai region when they
went missing their bodies were found in
a village more than two weeks later
zeida had been beheaded
the court's verdict guilty and 51 of the
54 accused given the death penalty
the court has made its decision on the
charges of terrorism war crime murder
participation in an insurrection
movement and the act of war crime
through mutilation this military court
is sentencing you to death for these
crimes
but questions remain about the possible
involvement of state security what is
clear is that the prosecution
has not
looked into uh state responsibility and
so now um you know there is a verdict um
but um there is a clear need from the
authorities to look up uh higher up the
chain of command and to investigate
further senior officials who ultimately
may bear responsibility for the planning
and the ordering of
those killings
the most senior person on trial was an
army colonel who was sentenced to 10
years in prison his lawyer described the
ruling as a miscarriage of justice
i must stress with considerable
bitterness today's verdict colonel jean
de gea mambuene was charged with crimes
that he didn't commit he was charged
with an act of dissipating orders and
failure to assist a person in danger
this trial is a set up
we will appeal this verdict
colonel mambuene is a good man who
served his country and he shouldn't be
charged with such a crime
at the time of the murders congolese
government forces were trying to put
down an armed uprising that killed and
displaced thousands of people
one theory was militia men killed the
two aid workers because the u.n failed
to stop the army's attacks against them
saturday's verdict is likely to be
appealed and since a 2003 moratorium on
executions sentences are likely to be
commuted to life in prison
zanbasravi al jazeera